Netflix's latest original feature, starring
Thor himself, Chris Hemsworth, alongside Bollywood
sensation Randeep Hooda, is about as high-octane
a thriller as any action fan could hope for.
Through all the captivating action sequences
and frenetic fight scenes, Extraction actually
manages to tell a pretty complex story with
an ambiguous ending that has fans abuzz with
theories.
Extraction follows protagonist Tyler Rake,
a former member of the Australian Special
Air Service Regiment now working as an off-the-books
mercenary.
At the film's outset, he's engaged by fellow
killer-for-hire Nik Khan to rescue the son
of India's leading drug kingpin, who is currently
being held for an exorbitant ransom by rival
Bangladeshi drug lord Amir Asif.
A hiccup during Rake's attempted "extraction"
of his target brings down the wrath of Saju,
another former special operative currently
in the employ of the Bangladeshi drug lord.
Rake and Saju engage in a complex game of
cat and mouse…
"Ovi, it's Saju!
I'm here to take you home!"
"Saju!
I'm here!"
"Sit down and shut up!"
But they ultimately end up working together
to outwit the authorities on their tails.
As far as action-thriller set-ups go, it's
about as compelling as they come, but viewers
hoping for a clear-cut resolution that sees
charismatic anti-hero Rake victoriously walking
away from an explosion in slow motion were
left with a real head scratcher.
Let's break Extraction's ambiguous ending
down with a little help from the film's director,
Sam Hargrave.
At the beginning of the film, shark-eyed mercenary
Tyler Rake has an obvious death wish.
His ambivalence toward his own continued survival
is a big part of what makes him such a deadly
merc.
We learn that much of Rake's nihilism stems
from the death of his son, a loss that still
haunts him.
It's his relationship with Ovi, his target
for extraction, that ultimately saves Rake
from himself.
As Rake begins to form a bond with Ovi, he
no longer sees the drug heir as a simple job,
but rather a kid whose life has become more
important than his own.
"Can I ask you something?"
"It's Rake."
"What's Rake?"
"My last name."
By the time the film reaches its climactic
shootout on the bridge, Rake takes a mortal
wound to ensure Ovi's safe escape.
This emotional beat lands because we actually
believe that Rake no longer wants to die,
but has chosen to give up his life to save
Ovi's.
So Rake gets to go to his grave feeling like
he redeemed his soul, while Ovi lives to fight
another day.
Satisfying ending, right?
Not so fast.
After Ovi's daring escape, the film presents
a very unexpected coda.
In the final moments of Extraction, Ovi jumps
into a peaceful swimming pool, a mirror image
of Rake's first scene jumping off a cliff.
When he comes up for air, he sees a blurry
figure standing in the background who bears
a striking resemblance to Rake, but the film
ends before we get any actual confirmation.
So, what gives?
As it turns out, Extraction's final moments
were left open to interpretation by design.
Hargrave weighed in on the mystery surrounding
this final scene.
He told Collider:
"We had a version of the movie, and we tested
it a lot, and it was not surprising that a
lot of people wanted the character to live,
and some people wanted him to die...If people
on one hand feel like the story is complete
and is a story of redemption through sacrifice,
then for them, it'll be where the kid is imagining
[Rake standing there], and then now you go,
'Yes, I'm satisfied.'"
Hargrave went on to explain, quote, "If you
feel like you love Tyler Rake, and you love
Chris Hemsworth, and you want a sequel, and
you're like 'There's no way, you can't kill
him!' then that's Tyler Rake standing there
looking at you.
So we kind of purposefully did not pull focus
to the character standing there."
For fans looking for a little more closure,
Hargrave shared that the original screenplay
for Extraction included a much more definitive
ending.
In screenwriter Joe Russo's intended story,
Tyler Rake very explicitly dies on the bridge,
completing the character arc he started when
he dove off that cliff in the initial scene.
Hargrave told Collider that the test audiences
weren't crazy about the sacrifice, however.
He dished:
"People were torn; it was almost down the
middle.
We want to appeal to as many people as possible
without compromising the integrity of the
story.
And so, we think a pretty good compromise
is to make an ambiguous ending."
Hargrave ultimately admitted that he prefers
to imagine that Rake is dead by the film's
conclusion, claiming that he felt as though
Rake had redeemed himself through sacrifice.
For fans in desperate need of finality, that's
probably the best you're going to get.
The rest of us will have to learn to live
with the ambiguity, at least until we get
an Extraction 2.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.